now you had some some choice words to
say about the bohmian pilot wave
theory okay why do you not particularly
like it
oh i i do particularly like it um so
i i actually think that um
like i don't think i believe it um but i
think that is a really
really important theory to have in mind
because a lot of the things that we want
to say about
quantum mechanics all we think is like
obviously true about quantum mechanics
um biomechanic bohmian mechanics
provides an
excellent counter example for so it's
something to like always be keeping in
mind
um when you're talking about the
foundations of quantum mechanics
and yeah like i think it's an ingenious
theory i think that
it doesn't extend well to relativity uh
which is why i don't think it's true
but for just straight up quantum
mechanics itself
it is like yeah just such a beautiful
counter example to a lot of things
people say
yeah i heard you say that on the eigen
brawls podcast that it doesn't extend to
well you said that it's
non-renormalizable but i wasn't able
to find that result do you can you
there's a paper on that
i'm assuming there are some papers on
this but it's not
it's not that it isn't possible but that
um
that it seems so it is probably possible
to reproduce the
um like the the phenomena of
of special relativity but not to
reproduce the sort of like
underlying um beauty of special
relativity which is like
relativity that um like you know frames
of reference don't matter and that sort
of thing
there's a paper a fairly recent paper
2019 this guy named pintonetto
and strove i don't know if you heard of
them no okay
okay well they showed that with a
bohmian interpretation
you can have you can have quantum
gravity
and in a way that doesn't have the
the parts of heterotic string theory and
supersymmetric string theory and
and loop quantum that they have some
pastiferous parts to them when it comes
to
quantizing gravity so what they used is
an approach of canonical quantum gravity
and apparently
when you use a bomium interpretation it
helps
form some even predictive aspects of
quantum cosmology
so that's why i was wondering why is it
non-renormalizable when
like i couldn't find that result and i i
heard you say that on the eigenbros
podcast and i was like where's and then
they're like yeah it is non-normalizable
i'm like what yeah
and i search for this but i could yeah
okay so there i
don't know if i said not normalizable
but
um definitely like the thing that i was
thinking of was
um like that that it is frame dependent
um so it has like a privileged frame of
reference i think
which is quite like not in the spirit of
of relativity yeah yeah even if it can
reproduce the results
and and like to be fair like if it can
reproduce the results very well or even
like have
good um predictions about like you know
where where all these things are gonna
go
then then that is very exciting and we
like you know maybe should
give up on like the beauty of relativity
a little bit if it's going to be useful
um so i'm not like i don't have a strong
position on that but my
my like sort of gut feeling was like
having not read this paper that you're
mentioning
um that like if it had to have like a
sort of privileged frame of reference
that it would probably make the
math of it like kind of too hard to like
be really workable
um and so that was why i wasn't
a fan of it like i didn't feel like it
could extend well